you have you ever make a beam yes I
actually made my UFC debut yeah
with him in 2014 yeah and we had a I've
always been kind of a nonchalant chill
you know your cousin is always telling
me like hey man you take pictures with
these guys take pictures with your boss
but I've always been like okay just like
yeah normal me it's not thing like crazy
fanatics for me but I do realize how
important it is to be more like
appreciative of those things yeah but
yeah I met him and 2014 and we were
actually supposed to fight together
March of this year March 4th on the same
corner he was supposed to fight Ferguson
yeah and I was on there and then after
the fight his manager was facetiming me
and I spoke to Kobe even as his manager
on Holi Holi yeah so I was I was
facetiming with those guys just talking
about my fight and yeah I did a video we
did a program talking about some of the
things that people would perceive as
being odd like for instance some of the
things that you know he has said for
instance after he'll finish a fight me
thank you God everything God gave me
he'll say and it's kind of the bridge to
cap where people are like what is he
saying what is he doing for instance
after he'll finished the fight he
doesn't point to himself just like like
you after you finish your fight you
point up a bow by submission Kimura
[Music]
so he's directing that attention to the
one who gave him the ability to throw
the punch right to be there he's the
creator that happens in earth so he's
saying not me up and he's saying it humm
did it last ok like what does that mean
he's saying thank God thank God right
and then he'll fall another thing I'll
talk about he'll prostrate and people
like was he kissing the ground
no he's thanking again the creator and
many people don't know that Jesus peace
be upon him he also fell on his face
when he prayed and hey it's in the
Gospel of Matthew 26:39 and he says and
he went a little further and he fell on
his face and prayed to who himself know
he prayed to the Creator so this is the
same thing that he was doing and we
trying to bridge that gap and then I
actually invited him I said look you've
been on this show that show that area
wanna we what's the guys go on and honey
you need to come out of these show like
I brother here so God willing inshallah
we'll have a khabib with us watch the
game show lots of detail make sure you
watch the Deen so watch the deed show by
students all across the future
[Music]